so how's that mom and kid getting across
there's no raft down there
so there's just a lot of money being
made here either they do it they're
gonna kill them
that's a stash house just to cross from
that side of the river to this size
they're paint these guys like i said
they're out here risking their lives
and at the end of the day for what so
what's the business model of this this
guy here definitely
sounds like martell
there's a raft crashing let's go that
way we don't know where the hell they're
at but they know exactly where we're
once at get into the united states they
basically know they have a free pass
what do you guys think the solution to
this thing is yeah
they all went back yeah
[Music]
the kids took off that's sad in the
morning they're they're the ones that
get
screwed
[Music]
good afternoon guys here in mcallen
texas a few miles from the u.s mexican
border
in the rio grande river as many of you
know
there's been an influx of migrants
coming over the last few months
and as many of you also know it's sort
of hard to get
a story that's not biased uh depending
what network you watch is sort of
what story you're gonna get so we're
gonna do this a bit differently
and this is about seeing the situation
through the eyes of the locals
so i had a local reach out to me he said
do you want to get on the rio grande
and i can show you what's going on
currently and i said definitely let's do
this
so i'm going to give it my best guys uh
everyone has an opinion
everyone has different views of looking
at the world
my goal in this series there's going to
be a few videos here
is to really capture this situation on
the ground
level uh more listening less talking i'm
no expert
on the border situation i'm fully aware
of that
so let's dive in push the boundaries
as much as we can but obviously i won't
be able to get in everything
or every view of this situation but from
what i've seen so far
it's quite it's saddening
it's interesting it's important so today
on the rio grande with the local
let's see what we can get into
[Music]
here we are i guess the river's on the
other side there
we're gonna head that way we're gonna
head that way we got
raul navigating this
this mission yeah somewhat okay
so what's the story here bro how do we
get through this we're going to have
somebody open the door for us
you know someone who knows someone of
the gate is actually private property
okay so even though border patrol
doesn't like it or anything
the property belongs to irrigation
district
so they're going to come and open the
gate for us okay there that irrigation
district
even though it sounds like it's a county
or a state uh entity it's not
it's a private entity so that's all
private property camera down
i'll use the record i can record yeah
usually government stuff it's not okay
those it's in the view of the camera
there's nothing to do about it i always
push everything to the limit that's why
i know how far i could go without
breaking the law
like yesterday that's a bus
full of illegal immigrants coming this
way
all right guys so that's how these
things go sometimes when you're
getting into the harder shoots which
this is
we're gonna have to do this again
tomorrow
day two on this mission we're on we got
our guy our contact
with the boat who has the access
now we're getting on the rio grande
okay now the body that they found down
by about 50 miles south of us they
haven't confirmed that it's hurt yet or
not
i guess it's a missing person in that
case
they could also trace it when the calls
come in and stuff so
they just got to get a warrant for it
that's it
so i want to be clear this is still the
u.s side
it's just the fence is back from the
river so we didn't cross into mexico
this is still
u.s okay thank you
a lot going on as you can tell here's
border
border patrol the river obviously
i don't know what that is that's a pump
house that's the pump house okay
they've got generators there that way
the electricity shuts off the right
story will supply water
to the city of mcallen and wherever else
all right and here's our boat ramp huh
yeah we got the boat coming down this is
raul's friend
raul little background he's part of the
united
navy which in short what are you guys
doing out here
basically we got a crisis going on
people float
fleeing from their home countries headed
to the united states a matter of fact i
was looking at a facebook a little while
ago in
la jolla they got about 600 people
detained within it within two hours
so but united cajun navy you guys i mean
and guys i want you to let you know
without these guys i wouldn't be getting
here that's for sure we got nothing to
do with immigration or any of that stuff
we're just trying to show the people in
the world that you know what
there is a problem of people coming this
way for whatever reason they're fleeing
their country
every morning around five in the morning
down there in that fence scenario that's
where they put that gate down there
okay you're finding a bunch of illegal
aliens hidden there so there's no
guarantees sometimes they're
busier than others obviously yeah
exactly but there's certain times that
are busier
than others because they know the change
of shifts for law enforcement so are we
hitting a busy time
we should be hitting one it's mexico
that's right
that's close you see how you have the
the dirt that comes down
yeah cleaned areas yep that's where
people come down through those areas
right there
okay i mean i'm going to start with some
basic questions but
have you seen a begging like there's a
big increase
or tough to say or nobody's really
counting or how does that work
well i can't tell you number wise uh the
only way to look up the stats and see
what the stats show and everything else
and
and take it from there but yeah like
that physically you see people in the
line
waiting to get on the rafts come across
and and they'll they'll
go back and forth two or three reps at a
time yeah he said he was there
everything's gonna be over here
that cooperation we told him that water
patrol supervisor
all right that's what i'm telling you
there's they have
gag orders on them where they can't say
nothing yeah but you know what they want
the store to be out there
yeah they'll they'll give us inside
information and stuff
it's your buddy john with a sweet boat
the hell out the boat look at the truck
yeah truck's pretty dumb
slowly no guarantees on what we're going
to see
[Music]
depends the day the time a whole bunch
of factors
but one thing we're going to learn is
exactly about what's going on
here currently from these guys who are
out here all the time
so let me ask you this raul yeah
you you and john have the the
bulletproof vests on but uh
we're out here without him is that like
the dad with the helmet and the kid
doesn't have one
you're safe don't worry my son you are
safe
you don't see i'm the one getting wet
and this is maya maya's also in the
united
cajun navy should we wear these or no no
okay there's nothing here
you want to put one i put one on i can
swim pretty well but if i get shot then
i don't swim off we don't need it and i
mean unless it's an emergency but
yeah they said life jack store they're
just y'all canal there's a donut up here
we'll get out of the area something's
wrong we'll get out of there don't worry
all right
no bullets but occasionally we're all
going home today remember that
oh people live right here
we'll
[Music]
or ranchers or whatever i love the river
wow so the homes are right here
and then these are the pathways or
what's going on exactly the majority of
these where you see the cleared out area
they're the pathways where people come
down
okay you'll see areas like they got
debris there
whatever debris they might have thrown
water bottles coke cans
their clothes and stuff like that okay
so what's the law here we can be on
on this side of the river the middle of
the river to our left to my left is the
united states the middle river to the
to the right is going to be mexico so we
could be in the middle of the river to
the left only
we can't cross into mexico because if we
do that means we have to come to a port
of entry
to come back to the united states even
though we are on the water raw walk us
through exactly what's going on
currently at the border like what are
you seeing you guys live down here
there's been an influx obviously of
migrants over the last few months
what's really going on what what happens
when they cross
literally since the new administration
took office
basically they made an open door for
people to come into the united states
once they get to mexico over here in
reynosa
they'll cross they'll cross the river in
rafts or however they're gonna cross
once they get into the united states
they basically know they have a free
pass
because the new administration took
office they have a hundred day uh
100 days no no deportation so what that
means is if you're
uh otm other than mexican you will cross
it
can you bring the mass down i just wanna
otm otm stands for other than mexicans
basically you're from mexico they'll
deport you back to mexico if you're from
anywhere
anywhere else they'll allow you into
this country what about
middle east africa those countries as
far as i know those countries will be
we will be deported back okay so other
than mexicans
the migrants come over what i've seen so
far is mostly women and children
the majority is women and children so
what's the business model of this they
have a
coyote on this side that they're paying
to navigate them through here
yeah basically what they're doing
they're paying somebody on that side
which
what they'll do is they'll stage them in
a stash house yep
from there they'll say you know what
they're monitoring border patrol
once they're monitoring the the their
movement and stuff they'll decide to
bring them down to the river
so you know what coast is clear they'll
go ahead and bring them across but
okay if they're if we're if our border
patrol is taking them in no matter what
then why do they need
coasters clear because not everybody
wants to be cut
like if you're from south america uh
like you said you're from south america
they're the ones who are going to
get caught and get released okay but
what they do is they'll send the
families and stuff one direction
and then the other directions where
they'll send your africans your chinese
and all those other people
so they could get into the country since
border patrol's tied up on one side
they sent them to the other side and
they're they're able to try to get into
the country
so there's just a big game right now cat
and mouse yes
okay what about the border guys over
here the u.s guys
what's their story right now basically
they're trying to do their job but they
can't
due to the owner the 100-day no
deportation
these guys are risking their lives
putting their lives on danger trying to
do their job they're out chasing people
through all rugged kind of terrain some
get hurt
some are not protected by the vaccine
and stuff do the kovit
but they're out here doing their job
because that's what they get paid to do
and like i said at the end of the day
they get demoralized because they're
they're not able to do their job
correctly
the illegal aliens are saying hey here i
am you're my taxi ride and stuff and
it's like come on these guys like i said
they're out here risking their lives
and at the end of the day for what they
need to they need the nation i know you
know what there is a problem
with the immigration problem with our
administration and something needs to
give and they give quickly
that way these guys can do their job
efficiently and get things done right
is there an increase of guys here
because i noticed in my hotel
there are more of these guys yes what
happens right now since
they have so many people crossing yeah
they're bringing out border patrol
agents from all around the country
this way they're setting them up at
hotels and stuff and that way they're
able to be in this area
for whatever time period is needed so
there's just a lot of money being made
here
there's a lot to just imagine what
they're charging and this is coming from
some of the people we've talked to
yeah just to cross from that side of the
river to this size
they're paying 3 500 3 500
just across just a river itself they
have their
their smuggler they bring them across
puts them to the united states side hey
get out get out get up and then
he'll go right back and load up another
one and just okay but what i was saying
was
if you were a solo person honduran
guatemalan whomever
and you wanted to do it yourself there's
no way to get to this line without
running another damn they would have to
play the cartel so the people
that own the ranches here they have to
let the coyotes and the cartels just
control their land or whatever
basically yes the way it happens in
mexico either they do it they're gonna
kill them
well they might be getting paid because
you know what you know what here
shut up stay out of my way okay option
one or option two is like they'll kill
them
yeah and it can also be looked at is a
lot of people are fleeing
bad situations and i bet they can feel
good about it oh we're
we're letting them to a better life type
thing is that possible
i think they just do it out of fear if
they're the landowners i think they just
do it out of fear because it
and and if deeper into mexico you'll
have different cartels going say you
know what
i'm taking over your land and that's it
and what do you do
yeah you don't go to the cops
most of the cops are paid off so
something you don't realize until you go
to a lot of the world and realize that's
how the systems work in different places
and you come back to the states and
you're like
oh wow if some mafia dude says they want
to use my land
i can actually talk to the cops and go
through a process here
yeah but usually you don't have someone
that goes up to you and says i'm going
to
take away your land i'm gonna use your
land that doesn't even happen at the end
of the day
there's no way the hell they could do it
on the west side exactly
so guys it can be fair to say that
there's no there's no crisis here
there's you don't see much
i mean it all depends where you're
standing
okay if you gotta remember this is a
long river
a long border yeah so just because we
don't see it in one part that means it's
not happening somewhere else
as soon as we're out of sight they'll
cross waiting for us
so what do we do hide and then hit full
throttle back
no i'm gonna try to go that way and
slowly come back so it'll hear the boat
but they can you can hear this engine
from way down the river
trust me they're monitoring everything
they know exactly where the hell we're
at
because they said they got scouts they
got scouts over here
you don't see them and the reason why
you don't see them the other day i was
having a conversation yelling at
somebody there was somewhere in that
brush
they're yelling at me i'm yelling at
them we're communicating back and forth
so that's what i'm telling you that we
don't know where the hell they're at but
they know exactly where we're at
you can't see them but they can see us
so they see gringo with a gopro
they don't know what the hell you're
holding it looks like a mic do you know
their old abandoned buildings and stuff
i'm gonna assume they're stash houses
and they've been there for a long time
so why would they dump all their clothes
before getting over the border
no what happened i that they're stash
houses so the stash houses
it's all the debris that's left over
when they change and stuff what does it
do with all the stuff
there's a wrath crossing let's go that
way all right
we got action
and that's that raft just went back i
think
yeah let's just hold on let it let it
come this way
yeah but okay the part i'm not
understanding is if they can get over
and
border patrol will take them in no
matter what other than mexican
then why why have lookouts because we
don't know what exactly crossed you
might have had a few people
carrying packs of drugs or something
okay or like i said that's the people
they don't want
they want to they don't want to get
caught whether they're from africa china
russia
the other people that pay high dollar to
come into this country
well i said maybe the normal people pay
15 000 to come from
guatemala this way 15 000 from guatemala
yes how's that possible why do they come
up with the money i have no idea
yeah they took it up all right guys
there was a raft that i don't think the
gopro captured
but it went right up so right here in
this area yeah
don't be fooled that it's a family just
having leisure time that family is out
there or whoever it is
they're all going to be reporting down
river
to the people down the river hey you
know they're all watch out
so guys just to make it clear if these
were
normal asylum seekers they wouldn't care
that we're here they just go over
right because once they're there they're
they're let in right
well like even though they know they're
going to be caught but what happened
they're the ones
on the us side yeah you don't want your
own people caught either
the scouts are watching out for border
patrol boats and stuff like that
like what happened if they all suddenly
come in the raft and a boat is there
and it's border patrol now there are
people that are
maneuvering those boats to the united
states are going to get caught
they get caught yes oh they don't want
their people coming i don't know that i
don't want those wraps too
you need to understand because they're
smuggling did you understand that is
that just people that are wanting to get
caught across there's
people that are wanting to come across
and not get caught or people that are
wanted from
you know sexual whatever crime people
wanted for other crimes and from
other countries they're trying to sink
their way into this place
okay so it's a bit of everything so the
guy paddling the boat
he could get he could get caught by u.s
borders yeah that's what they want
gotcha gotcha that i said that's really
why they have to watch what's going on
so their people don't get caught
imagine every time they they did
something
they have two or three wraps those wraps
are not expensive i mean those reps are
not cheap
yeah they're expensive so imagine they
lose a rap every time they come out
it cuts into their profit and everything
these days is about profit and money
that's why they charge what they charge
and and they don't want to put their own
people at risk or their operation
and it's the kids that get roped into
this crap the majority of time yes
you'll be surprised how training these
kids are
yeah how trained they are trust me
you've got little kids making 20 dollars
to sit there and play
and hey let me know if anybody shows up
like i said that's 20
in mexico it's a lot of that money so
the cartels will pay the the kids
they'll pay them whatever they pay them
i don't i'm not i'm just giving an
amount but yeah
they they pay them they're like they're
scouts believe it or not
yeah wave to them they're all way
yeah he's moving it's just a little
change
like these might have been ready to
cross right now but we just yeah go
can we go quick can we get up there and
see it
they're running down
no but go quick because they're gonna
pull it up
[Music]
they're down in the in the grass
oh he's got to go
it's like border patrol you have border
patrol sitting here
yeah i mean they go that way they come
this way yeah
how does this make you guys feel living
living on the border
what's happy sad well it's sad
what they're doing because you know what
they take the risk and they might not
even make it
we actually found a dead body farther
down
on the mexico side so we couldn't
approach it but they looked like they
were sliced in half
so like i said they do take the risk and
there's other people that might get the
females that might get raped and
whatever else might happen along the way
so it's it's it's saddening because you
know what
they put their lives at risk for what
they're doing how do you feel about
on the u.s side living on this side and
what's going on
from your perspective at the end of the
day like if you don't have people like
you that come out here and uh
let people know around the world what's
going on you don't you don't know what's
going on
you don't see it it's like normal life
here in the valley yeah yeah yeah that's
true
good point so in mcallen the the big
city over the border here it's like
until raul showed me the and these are
in other videos like
where the covet testing is where the
christian
uh the catholic organization is that's
sending people away
in the airport bus stations you would
never really know anything's happening
you won unless i went in with you
[Music]
so this is the crossing the us
once he gives it clear they'll people
come down the hill or wherever they're
hitting back they'll come out from
behind that come out this way
so are you do you know any of these guys
nope you just wave at them and let them
know
we pros no threat to them see there's a
raft right that's what they're coming up
through
okay right across from where he's
looking
they actually throw a ladder up they
have they'll throw a ladder up on that
fence
and they'll hop that fence right there
in front because once you cross right
there
you got an empty parking lot you got a
plaza yeah and you got hundreds of
people already walking there
doing shopping in those plazas so once
they cross
they get lost into those people if the
wall's not working why not what's the
point if it's
the wall is not there to actually stop
anybody the wall is there just as
another tool to help out border patrol
that's what people don't don't
understand okay that wall like i said
you put a ladder against it
in new mexico i believe or in arizona
they literally built a ramp to drive
over the wall
they literally they literally did that
that wall is just another tool you got
agents that are your tool
you got your your vehicles your atvs
your motorcycles your horses
your your aerostat balloons that are up
there and stuff
you got drones if they fly helicopters
how is it a tool if it's not working so
well
it does because what happens instead of
set up this is your fence right here
okay instead of pretend there's no fence
yeah imagine how many ages you would
have to have in that area to monitor
this area okay
but if there's a fence you got an
opening over here and open over here
that means you just really got to put
one agent over here one over here
and one maybe in the middle so not
everyone comes with their own ladder
is what you're saying yes cause i said
you could actually go around the fence
what about going under it
going under that i have no idea i know
in other states that have done tunnels
yeah but as far as going under it i have
no idea it has not been done here yet
on the way back there's a tunnel oh yeah
there's a ton over there that they
sealed off but that that
uh is basically the old drainage system
into the city
okay and back in the day the cartel did
use that to smuggle drugs in the united
states because they would go into that
those huge tunnels take up their drugs
and do whatever they're going to do
so right now it's really hard to know
who exactly is coming over
but it's it's it's a collection of every
one right it's like
innocent mom it's a hard-working guy
from bad situation
it's drug guy it's human trafficker guy
it's not it's a mixture of everybody
that's why there's a right way to do
this in a wrong way the right way is to
come on
this is your footbridge come on come in
you're going to
walk in and say you know what i'm here
to claim asylum i got a problem in my
country there's a country i'm from
yeah and that's the proper way to do it
yeah not crossing the river and saying
hey
i wanna i'm seeking asylum
so let's see up there cameras oh on the
u.s side here
okay you're gonna see a cartoon stash
house
you're gonna see possibly a drug house
they have their own private ramps
they can launch a boat off at any time
the drug house
and and it's easy for them because
border patrol
spots them they want to get away all
they got to do is race back home and get
on the ramp and they're done
yeah so they're just watching out there
just saying
these guys are getting ready to just
pass
they're looking out and they're making
sure the air is clear
um and you guys wave to each other why
yeah well i mean we've got to be
friendly you know
let them know that we pose no threat to
them we're friends we're not
here to interrupt their their operation
we're not here to do anything against
them we're just here to video and take
footage and that's it
you know one let them know there's times
where we'll get into uh conversations
with them
or they'll say hey let us do our job we
say we pull no thread do whatever you're
gonna do
we're not cops or anything we'll let
them know hey their thing is their thing
we don't care we
getting involved we're here for a whole
different purpose
we're not border patrol uh here's some
more guys
behind you what's this well
they're the family right there
it's got a work badge there's some some
uh some waving going on
all gonna play the again they play the
part of course they have to bring their
family out here
they're gonna play the part that they're
here as a family but they're actually
looking up
you know somebody got to be getting paid
so how's that mom and kid getting across
there's no raft down there
they might head right down the other
side of the hill where we don't see it
or they might have dug a certain section
where they have it hidden or something
oh my god so that
mother and child might have come all the
way from deep into central america this
is the end of their journey yep it's the
last
last stand for them and they know if
they get their crossing spot right there
that
they've been using it's fresh
right so they know they spent
thousands and thousands of dollars how
many months do you think you get here
i've talked to some people on the river
they've taken two months uh long as i've
heard up to four months to get here
there's some people said i took two
weeks to get here but i didn't ask where
he was from
he's explaining to the woman whatever to
explain to her given her strategy of how
to get across
well they could say you know what you
see that tower right over there once you
get to that tower take a ride or
or whatever like i said because he is
pointing to this side and someone
talking to her so what he's telling her
who knows
right why would he point to the united
states there ain't nothing to point it
yeah what is this i don't know we're
starting to think that maybe the
cartoons took over this place and this
is where they launched out of
you saw those guys up there
mother and child i'm sure they're going
and they just need to get over and
that's i'm trying to get into the mother
and the child's head it's probably like
they're probably feeling nervous as hell
and super euphoric at the same time like
okay this is the last stop they probably
went through hell to get here
this is the last stop and once i get to
the u.s side i'm in
they know they're in because that's the
way things are right now
mother and children are not going to be
sent back other than mexican
from what raul said and maybe some
middle eastern or asian countries but
central south america they get there
they're in
i did the whole other video on like the
process of what happens
after they get to the u.s side
interesting how they all wave to each
other like they all understand like
don't infringe too much on me i won't
infringe
too much on you and there's that
you know game back and forth quite
surreal out here guys
you were saying the people from central
america most of them they're selling
everything they have
their home anything just to get over
here
anything so what do you got what do you
guys think the solution to this thing is
it's like one of the most complex topics
we have they gotta re-implement the
prior administration's policies
okay because what happened they had an
agreement with mexico
that way they would keep them on that
side they wouldn't come to this site
trump eventually made that make that
agreement with mexico the mexico
president is also mad with all this
open door policy because it hurts that
country with the country of mexico
why don't they protect their border
better
the mexican because they even have a
shorter border you're well they have
particularly practically the same border
but i can't answer that i have no idea
probably people getting paid off well
you you could say they have their
their we might run into the military
right now hovering above us or whatever
i said you do have their stuff now how
they operate i have no idea i can't tell
you
what they do or how they do it i can lie
to you and tell you something make them
something right yeah
that's not gonna happen don't do it yeah
let's clear up your
your confusion okay clear my confusion
please what is your confusion
my my i understand the whole part why
people want to go to a better life i
would do it 100
if i was in honduras and poor i'd be i'd
be the first guy
running over you know i get that part um
the confusion is why we can have on our
side like
why the legal process seems murky it
seems gray it's not really
like anyone can come over other than
mexican some of the men i think get sent
back because i've seen mostly women and
children
but almost like man well i've been
arrested before for doing something
that's why but i don't see anything i
don't see how this is sustainable like
how it can keep going
indefinitely that's what i'm trying to
do that's why
you don't find it confusing at all or
what what are you what's your take john
living here my thoughts are that um
can you cut the engine do you mind
actually i could but i don't want to
float into it okay yeah don't worry
[Music]
my thoughts are that or just speak loud
stupid thoughts
no i guess but i'm thinking that bayern
is getting all these people come
eventually all these people are going to
be uh
they'll become citizens yeah and those
are going to be votes for him exactly
he'll be dead by then well no but for
the democratic party yeah
so they're going to say who let me in
the democrats did so they're going to
stick with that
i mean okay but it's fair to say last
election
moore has hispanic i think the
republicans are kind of a hispanic
you're right hispanics and we do have a
lot of
even mexicans not hispanics we're
hispanics that we're from texas
i said you had mexicans from mexico that
do support trump also
it's not just us but what happened in
this case
if pretend you were from honduras yeah
and and they gave you a chance without
no problems to say you know what you're
an american citizen here's your papers
here's your
your social security right aren't you
going to be grateful to who did it which
was your president was a democrat
i mean you can dig so far too you can go
back republicans used to bring illegals
for cheap labor in in
central valley california i understand
all that i understand that but
in this case like i said these these
people are fleeing their country because
this person gave them an opportunity to
say come come
let's go you got 100 days that's
basically what he did
he didn't do it in that manner but in he
he basically ate you got 100 let's go
okay but okay
let's on the other side they come over
they have get asylum papers
they have to come back to a court date
in mcallen or wherever which probably
won't happen but
even if they don't you still go back to
you know what we're gonna give amnesty
to everybody
right like they did they tried back a
few years ago with the the daca and all
that stuff
and i know that's a very touchy
situation yeah
but like i said at the end of the day
they say hey you know what we're gonna
forgive everybody from this date on or
whatever
now what and then that
will piss off people i'll just give an
example my wife
my wife did everything the right way
she's an american citizen now
so why can't everyone how'd she come
over she came over with a resident card
she got a resident card and from there
she went ahead and started working and
stuff and then
she got her her process done
okay what about this though i i hired a
guy a long time ago
he came to the states when he was three
months old he doesn't even speak spanish
that's why that's a delicate situation
because what happens there
he doesn't even know mexico he would
have to go a case-by-case situation
when someone is detained and they're
thinking about deporting them back and
the judge would have taken
consideration because that is a delicate
situation yeah like them
they were born in mexico yeah and no
fault of their own they are over here
yes and now they want to deport them so
like i said that has to be worked out
and i guess he would have he would have
to actually prove you know what i have
been here since i was
three years old and prove that in some
way whether it's with school records or
whatever
yeah that way they could go and say you
know what we are going to let you stay
in this country
unless he committed a felony and
there'll be something different like
they
got him on a traffic ticket or something
that's totally wrong but
as if he did a felony he or he did
something to a minor or somebody you
know what
by all means is getting the heck out of
this country yeah because i don't even
want american citizens have done that to
kids and stuff to be in this country
what about the argument that
the current policy is because it's
humanitarian
it's helping people out they're coming
from a shitty situation but how do we
know their actual true story on
each and every single person maybe some
yes
but maybe some looking for the
opportunity like i would be i would be
running around yeah
and and i know a lot of people that live
here in the valley that are illegal
they're all good people i got nothing
against anybody you know you got the
right to do whatever to
to make your life and live your life and
and get ahead in life
never hold anybody down but like i said
there's also a right way to come into
this country and a wrong way to do it
yeah that bolt that out came upon them
in the water
was parked right there on this ramp
right here okay so that boat is the one
who showed up with them over there with
seven armed
armed people with machine guns so if you
pull one and one together
it's gonna equal two in this case
the state of texas should be spending
about 25 million every three months for
border security
how did i get those numbers the last
time we did this thing where they
brought in
a thousand uh national guardsmen and dps
and everything
that's what it came out to they got to
pay housing which are hotels for the
national guard
gotta pay hotels for dps yeah they gotta
buy they gotta pay for their food for
all three meals
and whatever else they're paying for
besides uh the payroll and everything
else so
they're spending about 25 million every
three months for board of security
25 million everything okay and then the
feds who knows huh yeah
what were they paying before well
nothing so what happened i said that's
before the surge oh
this is extra manpower dedicated for
border security yeah
through the state of texas okay so
they're gonna take away money from
education and whatever else to be able
to throw money to dps's fund
so they can support all this we think
that's special
that's a stash house i would say yes
what do you mean no ac means stash house
no that's just an abandoned building but
there's an ac unit right there
by the second window it's got to be used
too i mean
it ain't there just to be it i said you
put people up near the top floor to
watch
i said you got the bird's eye view of
whatever's going on on this side over
here do you see the type of glass that's
something
it's reflecting yeah and a barbecue pin
the governor of texas claims that this
is a war zone yeah they're paying dps
hazard paid
and right now i understand it's needed i
understand you know what we do got that
flux but
there is no need to say you know what
the valley is a war zone because you
went out to eat the other day alone
you didn't get shot at yeah we weren't
dodging bullets anywhere you weren't
wearing a kevlar vest
so the valley is not a war zone it is
actually safe to live with your family
and i understand everything's about
government funding and and that's
what it is you know what we need more
money for this we need more money for
that
so the governor tells the federal
government
these are our numbers this is what we're
doing this is the operations we're
running
well those operations like i said are
costing millions to do
so they want to try to get reimbursed if
for every person that comes in if
they're getting that packet
that packet like the rumor says a
thousand two hundred dollars they have a
picture of them they have the paperwork
they have all that stuff a lot like the
summer getting hotels they're getting
their meals paid for they're getting
clothes to put on and stuff
all paid for by somebody nothing's for
free in this world so
the catholic charity might be doing it
but they're getting government funded
the border patrol might be doing it but
they're getting government funding and
where did that government funding come
from
the normal taxpayers yeah and all they
have to do is get to
from this side this is the last step
once you get there you get all of those
things you're talking about
and then you can sort of dissolve into
the population because you can go
anywhere right once you get to the us
once you get those walking papers that
allow you to go anywhere in the united
states you can disappear anywhere
you don't have to come back for your
your court date okay but guys what don't
you feel
empathy for the mom
that's fleeing some situation with a kid
let me give you a story here
my dad was a vietnam veteran my dad
worked for the county
at that time maybe for about 17 years
for the
for the county he worked for the
sheriff's department
he lost his job for whatever reason i
won't go into detail on that but he lost
his job
he was almost two years without a job he
was living off credit card by credit
card this credit card pays this bill and
this one pays that bill
and so on he went to go ask for
government assistance
food stamps whatever they denied him why
that's why why they said he had two
vehicles he went yes i have two vehicles
i'm paying on both of those vehicles
i'm paying on the place that i live on
he went i got no money coming in haven't
had money coming in for almost two years
i'm a vietnam veteran i i've never asked
this country for
and for you to deny me the
one time i do come for help for y'all to
deny me my dad
then they said look at those and i'm
gonna excuse my word i use sob
look at those sobs in the lobby yeah
you're giving they're full of gold
watches
cell phones all this stuff and you're
gonna give them everything they want
money plus food stamps
and why i'm an american citizen they're
not
so that was the end of that my dad was
pissed so this is
one of the most politicized issues would
you say yes right now well
it was but then all of a sudden they put
a pause on it
the only there there's very few people
are pushing the issue now
maybe about two weeks ago three weeks
ago it was a heavy
issue but all of a sudden everything
went silent
why different flow or no no we got the
same
flow coming in and stuff and more and
the u.s side guys different reality even
just seeing nature
i mean no trash
two different worlds right on top of
each other and i don't want to say
mexico is a terrible country because
it's
not i've had great times in mexico city
and oaxaca i went to that was cool okay
uh it's a very much mixed up country so
this is not one of its charming
uh places not all mexico is like this
border zone that's for sure
[Music]
foreign
you think they live there or they're
coming over well he says he's fishing he
caught one fish
that's somehow how's the fish in here
you think that do you think they're here
they're locals yeah well the other ones
went up there to go hide you see
why go hide
[Music]
their scouts they're scouts all right
that's sad guys
[Music]
hello
the kids the kids took off no i got one
and a half of zombies that's sad
in the morning they're they're the ones
that get uh
screwed in all this part of the room and
they're just sitting up in the tree up
there see that
ah man they're all scared
kill it oh that looks like a uh
well those air mattresses yeah it's
stuck
[Music]
yeah that's got to be a tough job what
these guys are doing huh
makes it even harder with all this other
bs going on yeah
there's sensors on the ground that alert
them to someone across to a certain area
so you might get the sensor and say you
know what it just went off 20 times
they'll tell them if there's 20 bodies
that just passed so now if they only got
15 people here
they're they're out looking for those
other five bodies that they missed
i've never seen it people there before
and i've seen horses and stuff
so that that's very well just people on
the mexican side hanging out
on a hot day i'm gonna say yes for them
yes
okay what are those tires for they hide
behind those tires for coverage look
over here
behind you
[Music]
okay well that's that's a glimpse of
what it's like on the rio grande
cat and mouse game huh basically yes cat
and mouse
so we didn't see any boats crossing as
you as you could see
but it is a hot place from what i've
been told and from what i've seen with
the donna
processing facility right that's a
massive the message
yes expansion of what it was so thanks
for coming along on that guys i also
want to um
leave a link down below for the united
cajun
navy rolls part of it they help with all
sorts of disasters
and there's no way i'd be able to make
these videos without them
so if you want to be you want to give to
a
hurricane or tornado relief or even here
i don't know if you guys are doing
anything here yet
not yet um this is the organization
and lastly i gotta say this is this is
pretty difficult content to get and it's
confusing it's heavy
it's a difficult situation but the
stories need to be shown
hope you got something out of that i'll
have i'll have quite a few other stories
about the border region uh in the
playlist below
thanks for coming along until the next
one